now if you plan on celebrating the
fourth with your own
fireworks at home we do want to remind
you legal and safe fireworks
you can only buy those and they are on
sale right now there are more than 100
boos across clark county selling them
reminder if you are caught with illegal
fireworks which shoot into the air
you could face a thousand dollar fine if
you need to report illegal fireworks do
not call
911 please tell us that instead you
should use the
i spy fireworks website that's
ispyfireworks.com
please use that information and then
team up to patrol some
trouble spots we also want to tell you
this
just a reminder be courteous and mindful
when it comes to these celebrations the
loud unexpected booms can
cause people to panic they can pose a
trigger for those of us with ptsd
one october survivors veterans to help
the vegas strong resiliency center they
say suggest looking for things
that bring you into the moment if you're
having some problems so that's like
counting down to five and look at things
around you take a deep breath
this is one of the reasons why it's
important for you to let your neighbors
know
if you do plan to set off fireworks not
everybody wants to hear them